brian is in Columbus Ohio hey Brian how
are you take a look all day sure how can
I help about a set of question of I take
your class about a year ago and we are
absolutely beans and rice right now and
we're just being able to make minimum
payments on everything right now
mm-hmm and I just feel like we're not
getting anywhere
okay what's your household income 60 60
and how much is your house payment of
850 okay and how much are your car
payments of 450 well I have one car
payment I actually sold mine okay
450 on the remaining car yes and when
you sell about it down at 1400 I mean
14,000 you're upside down 14,000 I owe
14,000 I'm so far upside down I'm afraid
to sell it upside down about four grand
on it well I mean that's 10 months of
these payments right it's not much you
must have a horrible interest rate on
that line absolutely we've made a lot of
bad decisions yeah I mean there's only
two things you can do that this is what
we call the the log jam you've heard
that phrase and that's from when the old
Lumberjacks back in the day would float
the logs down the river and they would
hit the bend in the river and they would
jam up and couldn't make the corner and
it creates a stop up and that's what
you're facing you're kind of stopped up
here and those guys had one solution to
that they as bad as it was I would lose
some of their timber they'd cut but
they'd light some dynamite and throw in
the middle of it blow it up and so how
do we blow this log jam up
mathematically that's what you're facing
and there's only two sides to that it's
what can we sell and what can we do to
get our income up that's where my mind
always goes as those two directions are
you working extra yes I work working two
jobs right now it's just pretty crazy
yeah okay the second job what's it
paying it just depends on how quick I
get it done I'm a contractor so I'm just
sticking up evening jobs mm-hmm okay
shut up I mean what kind of money are
you making on that uh probably two to
three hundred a week okay
my question was a lot of our debt as
little stuff like little $2,000 credit
cards would it be wrong to maybe stop
paying on some of them so we can pay
some of the other ones off it doesn't
fix it though
it's still there you know I mean it's it
doesn't it doesn't break the log jam up
I thinking I'm probably going to sell
the car if we can't get easier nothing
we can do to get the income up is
anything else we can sell we've pretty
much sold everything we can and have put
everything out of our life that costs
anything now
well $450 to go a long way in your
budget right right I said that that's
the quick fix the other thing I could do
is re investigate this side job are you
making enough is there something else
you can do as a side job that's included
in the 60 thousand you gave me no no
that's extra just it varies so much I
try not to count on it you know it's
kind of like a bonus to us yeah but it's
like thousands it's like 800 bucks a
month right correct yeah you can make
1,500 a month delivering pizzas yeah
your wife doesn't work outside the home
no how many kids have you got three okay
a one a four and a five year old how
long have you been working on this
almost a year we went there plasticize a
year ago Wow
and it just it just you know hurts our
feelings every month when it's like all
we're doing is making minimum payments
and nothing yeah I don't blame you I
don't blame you I don't have I don't
have a perfect clear answer the two
things that occur to me is to change
something in the extra job side of the
equation so if we can add another
thousand dollars to the pile that way
and I really probably would consider
selling this car because four and fifty
bucks goes a long way even if you got
four thousand dollars more in debt you
at least you got some cash flow moving
that way but not paying and then turn
around paying later doesn't really fix
the equation
you